in this segment we'll introduce a simple
but powerful tool the basic counting
principle which we will be using over
and over to deal with counting problems
let me describe the idea through a
simple example you wake up in the
morning and you find that you have in
your closet for shirts three ties and
two jackets in how many different ways
can you get dressed today to answer this
question let us think of the process of
getting dressed as consisting of three
steps three stages you first choose a
shirt let's say this one and you have
four choices of shirts but each shirt
can be used together with one of the
three available ties to make three
different shirt tie combinations but
since we had four choices for the shirt
this means that we have 4 times 3 equals
12 shirt tie combinations finally you
choose a jacket each shirt tie
combination can go together with either
jacket and so the fact that you have two
jackets available doubles the number of
options that you have
leading to 24 different options overall
so 24 is the answer to this simple
problem and how did the number 24 come
about well 24 is the same as the number
of options you had in the first stage
times the number of options you had in
the second stage times the number of
options you had in the third stage let
us generalize suppose we want to
construct some kind of object and we're
going to construct it through a
sequential process through a sequence of
our different stages in the example that
we just considered the number of stages
was equal to 3 at each one of the stages
you have a number of options that are
available so in our example at the first
stage we had 4
options at the second stage we had three
options and at the last stage we had two
options what is important is that when
you reach stage I no matter what you
chose no matter what you did at the
preview stages the number of options
that you will have available at stage I
is going to be that fixed number and sub
I so what is the answer how many
different objects can you construct this
way well just generalizing from what we
did in our specific example the answer
is the product of the number of choices
or options that you had at each stage
this is the counting principle it's a
very simple idea but it is powerful
it will allow us to solve fairly
complicated counting problems however
before we go into more complicated
problems let us first deal with a few
relatively easy examples in our first
example let us consider license plates
that consists of two letters followed by
three digits the question is how many
different license plates are there we
think of the process of constructing a
license plate as a sequential process at
the first stage we choose a letter and
we have 26 choices for the first letter
then we need to choose the second letter
and we have 26 choices for that one then
we choose the first digit we have ten
choices for it we choose the second
digit for which we have ten choices and
finally we choose the last digit for
which we also have ten choices so if you
multiply these numbers you can find the
number of different license plates that
you can make with two letters followed
by three digits now let us change the
problem a little bit and require that no
letter and no digits
be used more than once so let us think
of the process of a process by which we
could construct license plates of this
kind in the first stage we choose the
letter that goes the first letter that
goes to the license plate and we have 26
choices now let us go into a second
stage where we choose the second letter
because we used one letter in the first
stage this means that there's only 25
available letters that can be used we
only have 25 choices at the second stage
now let us start dealing with the digits
we choose the first digit and we have 10
choices for it however when we go and
choose the next digit we will only have
nine choices because one of the digits
has already been used at this point two
digits have been used which means that
at the last stage we have only eight
digits to choose from so by multiplying
these numbers we can find out the answer
to this question the number of license
plates
if repetition is prohibited let us now
consider a different example suppose
that we start with a set that consists
of n elements what we want to do is to
take these n elements and order them a
terminology that's often used here is
that we want to form a permutation of
these n elements one way of visualizing
permutations is to say that we're going
to take these elements of the set which
are unordered and we're going to place
them in a sequence of slots so we create
n slots and we want to put each one of
these elements into one of these slots
how do we go about it we think of
putting the elements in two slots
one slot at a time we first consider the
first slot we pick one of the elements
and put it there how many choices do we
have at this stage we have n choices
because we can pick any of the available
elements and place it in that slot next
we pick another element and put it
inside the second slot how many choices
do we have at this step well we have
only we have already used one of the
available elements which means that
there's n minus 1 elements to choose
from at the next stage at this point we
have used two of the elements there's n
minus 2 that are left we'd pick one of
them and put it in the third slot and we
have n minus 2 choices at this point we
continue this way we keep going on at
some point we have placed n minus 1 of
the elements into slots there's only one
element left and that element
necessarily will get into the last slot
there's no there are no choices to be
made at this point so the overall number
of ways that we can carry out this
process put the elements into the n
slots by the counting principle is going
to be the product of the number of
choices that we had at each one of the
stages so it's the product of the
numbers and n minus 1 and minus 2 all
the way down to 1 and this product we
denoted as a shorthand this way which we
read as n factorial n factorial is the
product of all integers from 1 all the
way up to N and in particular the number
of permutations of n elements is equal
to n factorial let us now consider
another example we start again with
general set which consists of n elements
and were
interested in constructing a subset of
that set in how many different ways can
we do that how many different subsets
are there let us think of a sequential
process through which we can choose the
subset the sequential process proceeds
by considering each one of the elements
of our set one at a time we first
consider the first element and here we
have two choices do we put it inside the
set or not so two choices for the first
element then we consider the second
element again we have two choices do we
put it in the subset or not we continue
this way until we consider all the
elements there's n of them and the
overall number of choices that we have
is the product of two times two times
two and times which is 2 to the power
and at this point we can also do a
sanity check to make sure that our
answer is correct let us consider the
simple and special case where n is equal
to 1 which means we are starting with
this set with one element and we want to
find the number of subsets that it has
according to the answer that we derived
this should have two to the first that
is two subsets which ones are they one
subset of this set is the set itself and
the other subset is the empty set so we
do have indeed two subsets out of that
set which agrees with the answer that we
found notice that when we count subsets
of a given set we count both the set
itself the whole set and we also count
the empty set all of these are subsets
of our set at this point we can now
pause and you can try to answer some
simple
questions of the same kind as the ones
that we just practiced